Leo dating the young gals normal or
creepy this is kind of his thing like
this is what Leo is known for it's what
he likes to do so who am I to tell him
no go for the old people well you're a
reasonable young woman who understands
virtue and moral order so that's what
that's who you are to tell him what to
do
return it to the Michael Knowles Show
expert
love panel we have Lauren smoker who
lives in La former Miss Hollywood
competed in both in Miss America and
Miss USA organizations
Lauren is our Millennial correspondent
Lauren thank you for coming on the show
of course thank you for having me back
we have again
Deborah
Leia a viral conservative content
creator from New York City and a recent
graduate of the University of Maryland
Deborah you are our gen Z correspondent
we have Billy Ray Brandt new to the
panel
an expert dating coach and viral content
creator from New Jersey speaking of love
and romance the state in which I was
conceived Billy Ray's Tick Tock has over
400 000 followers she's also very
popular on YouTube and Instagram another
Zoomer
thank you ladies for coming to the show
thank you I want to go down the line
we'll start
with our senior expert correspondent
Lauren and we'll just take it one by one
Leo dating the young gals
normal or creepy
you know it's hard to say because you
know look when Demi Moore dates a
younger guy it's a bit of a double
standard that we have here uh and
specifically though it is more common
with men so that is a good question to
bring up but important to also know why
do we think that it's only creepy when
the man is older uh in this specific
circumstance I think you know it's the
tale that we all hear or women go
towards an older man sometimes because
men do mature at not as fast as a rate
as women so I think that that is why we
see this pattern kind of a bit
I've been hearing this kind of anti-male
rhetoric since I was 11 years old oh
women mature or much faster than that
it's obviously true but it still hurts
nevertheless to hear it uh Deborah
normal or creepy
I'm in the middle I'm come from a Jewish
community so it's not uh unfamiliar for
me for people to get married to people a
lot older my grandparents are 10 years
apart but I do think that this is
representative of a larger phenomenon in
society where if people are no longer
pursuing marriages to have children why
does it matter what age you date why
don't you just go for the youngest
hottest thing Fresh Off The Shelf so I
think that this is something larger in
society but also this is kind of his
thing like this is what Leo is known for
it's what he likes to do so who am I to
tell them no go for the old people well
you're a reasonable young woman who
understands virtue and the moral order
so that's what that's who you are to
tell him what to do but but actually the
middle of the road response you just
gave I rescind my eye roll because you
made two very good points which is that
a lot of us have grandparents that have
an age Gap and they have a great
marriage and that's totally fine
but also that's not what Leo is doing
here it's not like Leo is finding some
younger woman and having a wife and
having lots of children he's just
kind of going out and doing that thing
that only married people are supposed to
do and then and then moving on and and
then to your point if that's it if this
is a total totally sterile relationship
emotionally spiritually and biologically
then who cares what age they are right
it's all just about feeling good and
titillating us for a brief period of
time Billy Ray what do you say
I don't think it's necessarily wrong
what he's doing
um if he was my dating client I
definitely wouldn't recommend it
um I think it is representative of you
know male female Dynamics in our society
um I think as a man he's looking for
Purity
um the ability to lead in a relationship
and I think a woman is looking for you
know the older man that's more
established in life but I I think at the
end of the day this is a constant cycle
that he finds himself in and um a cycle
that he will never really be fulfilled
in I personally believe in Traditional
Values I believe in the nuclear family I
think you'd find real fulfillment in
monogamy and having a family and and
he's um doing himself a disservice by
not partaking in that I agree so then
what's your advice to Leo how does he
break out of this cycle because I I see
it you know I try to put myself in his
shoes let's say I'm Leo DiCaprio I've
been a famous Hollywood star since I was
like 12 and I'm very good looking and
I'm super duper rich and I I know that
it's definitely very fun to do whatever
he does on the yacht with these 21 year
old girls so how do you convince
yourself to put that
titillating pleasure aside and actually
restrain some of your immediate pleasure
for something that is in the long term
much more satisfying what would you tell
him if he were your client
to go after a different type he has the
wrong type I I don't think he's he just
doesn't seem to be on the right track it
like I said it's a constant cycle he's
going out with the same exact woman
every time just a younger one once she
ages out he goes for the younger one so
um
I would say to find somebody closer to
his age start looking to values rather
than just pleasure but the problem for a
lot of these guys I think is that their
value is pleasure the thing that they
most value is just going out and having
fun and feeling good and so that's what
that's one of the problems of our modern
society is that the highest moral Maxim
is if it feels good do it Deborah you
had said that you know look if he likes
it if that's his thing who am I to judge
but hasn't that thinking gotten us down
this crazy social Rabbit Hole to begin
with
yes I am definitely not taking the
libertarian stance on here if I had the
choice to break it up why not use a
little bit of power but from a more
freedom perspective I just don't have a
horrible problem with people exercising
things that aren't illegal if she was
underage you know I'd be riding at dawn
to free that girl but I definitely think
that this is in society especially
modern society men and women but
especially young men are kind of enabled
to pursue one of two things and this is
the same throughout all of history it's
either fulfillment or pleasure and the
relationships that he's seeking are
purely pleasure based there's obviously
not going to be fulfillment if these
people are decades younger than you they
probably don't share the same values I
know that my values at 19 are completely
different than they are at 22 years old
and I can't even imagine what they're
going to be like when I'm 30 or 40 or
nearing Leo's age around 50. so I think
we need to encourage young men to start
pursuing and women just uh fulfilling
relationships rather than just you know
Tinder hinge swiping on all these apps
getting a little bit of a dopamine hit
on a random Tuesday night this is not
helping anybody in society but it's also
nothing new like he's not groundbreaking
this idea of just dropping off he
clearly doesn't want a family so men
pursuing pleasure is a Tale As Old As
Time right it's not a it's not a
breaking news story you know dog bites
man or man bites dog that a rich famous
hot guy is having sex with lots of young
women that's that's fairly normal but
what about this as a social Trend do you
I don't you if you can feel free to
refrain from answering the question if
you like but would you guys do it like
have any of you had the impulse to date
an older man do you would you if Leo
DiCaprio came knocking on the door I
assume every girl would say okay great
or or no I mean how how would you feel
about it personally Lauren well I was
actually telling a friend yesterday that
a couple years ago I had gone on a
couple dates with a guy and I didn't
find out his age until I believe it was
like the second or third date and he was
significantly older than me uh and so
when I say like I understand why certain
women
day older men for maturity purposes this
was the uh the extreme to where I
wouldn't date someone who was of the age
that he was uh but I think what we run
into especially living in Los Angeles
and Deborah might run into this as well
living in New York City I feel like so
many guys have what's called Peter Pan
syndrome and I've definitely dated some
and they just don't want to grow up they
don't want to commit and I feel like
women always have this natural maternal
Instinct for not only finding a spouse
but for finding a family and I don't
think women really grow out of that we
might go through phases but I feel like
men don't really even desire that until
later and so that's why we run into this
issue quite a bit do you think that
there are age mismatches just generally
in dating I say this because some of my
friends who didn't get married when they
were 25 they found that as they got into
their 30s
or maybe toward their late 30s all of a
sudden the dating pool looked totally
different
and so I mean the only thing I can think
of is if you're a freshman in high
school you're a freshman in college you
notice that the girls want to date the
upperclassmen that's the only way I can
think about it because I've been dating
my high school sweetheart and you know
then we got married and so I I think
okay well now there's this real problem
for the Freshman guy because the
Freshman all the The Freshman girls and
the sophomore girls and the junior girls
and the senior girls all want to date
the Junior and senior guys so what's the
Freshman guy going to do is is there a
similar thing at play for the guys who
are you know 22 to 25 they're not really
anywhere in their career they don't
really have any money they're not all
that impressive and then the older guy
maybe he's not a super rich hot famous
movie star like Leo DiCaprio but he's
more impressive than the younger guy he
can just swoop in and scoop up all the
22 to 26 year old girls yeah this is a
phenomenon that I had discussed with
somebody else before this panel
ironically it's like you're listening
into my conversations or something well
yeah I I work for the NSA and the FBI
and so we're all you know we there's a
lot of surveillance going on country I
just want a hundred bucks bet and you
were a Fed no I'm kidding but this is
something that I think is just common in
society especially in the older age
group like men from I'd say like 24 it's
around at least 28 at least the men that
I know are very focused on a career
because they want to be providers
eventually and I think it stresses them
out to date while they're also working
on building their income building a life
that they can provide and create space
for a wife to come in and protect the
children and her and everything so in
that time women I'm 22 I know that the
25 year olds they're not they're keeping
their heads down they're going to their
investment banking jobs working 120
hours a week they don't have any time
for girls so by the time comes around
where they feel comfortable to start
dating and exploring monogamous
relationships they're like 29 and why
would they not go for the youngest
hottest thing like this is just a cycle
that we find ourselves in and I don't
think women have any problem with it
because what woman is going to turn down
a man who's completely able to provide
for her and say you know what I'd rather
struggle for a few years so maybe that
this is just something that as marriage
rates go up like people are getting or
people are older when they're getting
married now than they were in the past I
think that's causing more divide because
if we're getting married at 16 years old
or 18 years old nobody's had time to
build up 10 million dollars but now if
we're waiting until we're 24 oh maybe
I'll wait till I'm 26 and I could find a
man who will buy me an even bigger house
and make me a range of a Rover mom even
sooner paper Pilates so I think maybe
getting married younger would mitigate
this problem but I don't think it's
going away anytime soon honestly Deborah
I love that for you the example of the
low status guy who is is an investment
banker in New York it's like yeah those
investment bankers no these poor guys
they're just hospitals
they're slaves to their bosses people
want to say that women submit to their
bosses you should see an investment
banker they say jump they say okay how
high how high that's that is true I
don't mean to beat up on the investment
bankers some of my best friends are
investment bankers now Billy Ray what
would you say to women and men in this
situation because one of my regrets it's
only a quasi regret because I trust in
Providence and I think everything is
happening in a way that is beautiful and
the outflowing of God's grace and so you
know I'm not complaining is what I'm
saying but
a quasi regret I have is I wish I had
gotten married sooner I wish sweet
little Elise and I had just gotten had
started having kids sooner than we could
have I don't know a dozen of them two
dozen of them see how fast we could go
what is your advice to young men who are
finding themselves in this little bit of
a crunch where
the girls their age are looking at the
older guys who are a little bit more
established and and they find themselves
maybe a little left behind so this is
something I talk about a lot kind of the
war on masculinity
um I think
the problem is women's standards are too
high and also men are kind of following
the social constructs that women are
setting for men
um so what I mean by that is
a lot of men are kind of like feminizing
their Tendencies today to try to like
appease women and fit their expectations
when in reality they're not really
appealing to woman at this point I don't
think they they realize that there's
this extreme disconnect but we're all
creating it we're all a part of the
problem and we need to be part of the
solution
and that's not just Leo DiCaprio that's
me and you that's that's Michael Jackson
saying I'm going to look at the man in
the mirror I'm asking him to change his
ways ladies thank you so much for coming
on where can people find you we'll go
down the line Lauren
uh Lauren smoka on Instagram Deborah
the Deborah Leia on Instagram as well
Billy Ray Billy Ray Brandt on everything
on Everett you can find me on MySpace at
Italian stallion318 you can find me on
live Journal at cool guy127 you can find
me on zanga you can find me on AOL
Instant Messenger thank you all for
coming on I'm Michael Knowles this is
the Michael Knowles show we'll see you
next time
thank you